so this left winger shows up to a trump
rally and harasses the trump supporters
why won't you wear the mask you guys got
masks
no no no why not
because i don't need it why do you need
it i would
yeah you should wear one because there's
a pen there's a global pandemic going on
yeah well you got yours i got mine on
yeah i'm trying to be safe
okay but you could infect somebody else
and and they could get sick why aren't
you leaving
would you please will you please rolling
excuse me will you please wear a mask
no please nope for the sake of other
people please wear one
please i'm begging you please no no i
don't think so
i don't think so how pathetic is that
dude
he's pathetic and unmanly
but he's also he's also deceitful and
dishonest
because on the one hand how to abase
yourself to get down and begging you
please wear the mask please do it and
that guy
that just extremely cool trump
supporters she's like nah
well the masks they'll make you safe
okay well you got a mask right so you're
safe
no the masks it's not that the masks
protect the wearer
the masks protect everybody else oh okay
so if that guy really believed that
if that liberal tick talker really
believed
that one this virus was extraordinarily
deadly
and he a apparently healthy millennial
was at great risk
from this virus and b
that the masks don't protect the wearer
the only way the wearer of the mask is
protected is if everyone else is wearing
the masks
then this guy basically just walked into
a a
hive of poison right because he the
whole point of the video is he's going
to show up and all these trump
supporters are not going to be wearing
masks
and he's going to beg them please wear
the masks but that means that he would
have to think that he's he's walking to
his death
because we know the virus is going to
kill everybody
right we know that if if someone else is
not wearing the mask then you no matter
whether you're wearing the mask or not
are at great risk
so this guy's walking to his death so
he's got to be a maniac
right no he just doesn't believe it none
of these people believe it
when they get down and they pester you
and they bother you and they fly across
the country
to go find you to pester you what
they're trying to do
is get you to acquiesce to their will it
has nothing to do with a virus
it has nothing to do with public health
has nothing to do with compassion
it's just a pure power play
by people who are even willing to abase
themselves to do it like this man
some people manly people are ignoring
these sorts of
rules disobeying them actually is a
better term
[Music]
you